Buenos días los líderes de la Unión
Europea se reúnen en Bruselas con una
variedad de temas encima de la mesa para
discutir desde las turbulencias
económicas hasta la ayuda a Ucrania Pero
antes se reúnen primero de todo con el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez que van a abordar los el
reciente informe sobre cambio climático
pero también la ayuda a Ucrania sobre
todo tras el acuerdo alcanzado por
Ucrania y Rusia sobre la exportación de
grano y las sanciones aplicadas por la
Unión Europea Bielorrusia en los
fertilizantes que podrían provocar
también problemas en la exportación de
grano tras ellos se espera que los
líderes europeos también aborden la
situación en Ucrania especialmente el
acuerdo alcanzado esta misma semana para
la exportación y aceleración de armas a
Ucrania Como por ejemplo un millón de
municiones para enviar a Ucrania en los
próximos 12
además también van a abordar la cuestión
con el presidente bolodimir stelensky
con el que van a hablar el mismo va a
explicar cuál es la situación en el país
y cuáles son la necesidades que tiene
sobre todo en materia de armas antes de
que acabe la reunión en todo caso
también van a abordar la cuestión
económica aunque se van a centrar sobre
todo mañana hoy también van a hablar
sobre también las medidas que se han
tomado de Cara a la ley de reducción de
la inflación con Estados Unidos una ley
que la Unión Europea considera que es
discriminatoria y por ello la Unión
Europea ha emprendido medidas Como por
ejemplo más ayudas públicas en la en
también en la digitalización pero
también en las ayudas verdes verdes como
las baterías eléctricas Y por último
también se va a abordar la política
comercial especialmente la situación con
los países de mercosur un acuerdo que
está bloqueado desde 2019 y que para la
comisión europea es de suma importancia